make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
you know I feel like right off the bat
people are gonna look at the title this
video and be like beyond omega-level the
Human Torch that's ridiculous right like
there's no way this guy is in a mega
level or beyond an omega-level threat as
we always do with this we're gonna go
under like the history the character
then we're gonna go and cover his powers
and the crazy things that he does so the
Human Torch aka Johnny Storm was of
course created by Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby and made his first appearance in
Fantastic Four number one in 1961
however Johnny Storm was not the first
Marvel character to be called the Human
Torch and in fact was really just a
reinvention of a Golden Age character
appearing in Marvel Comics number one
back in 1939 now unlike the original
Human Torch Jim Hammond Johnny Storm was
not an Android but instead was simply a
kid from a suburb in Long Island now his
mother died in a car accident when he
was young and he lived with his father
renowned surgeon Franklin Storm until he
becomes an alcoholic that squanders all
the family's money and eventually goes
to jail for killing a loan shark after
the loan shark accidentally shot himself
during an altercation with Franklin it's
kinda crazy now with his father in
prison Johnny dependant on his older
sister Susan who would later become the
Invisible Woman to essentially take care
of him now at age 16 Johnny's life
changes when he and his sister agreed to
join scientist Reed Richards and pilot
Ben Grimm on an experimental mission to
space and when their ship is exposed to
cosmic rays everybody on the ship gains
a different superpower and shortly
thereafter began operating as a
superhero team known as the Fantastic
Four because Johnny's powers allow him
to burst into flame and fly he adopts
the name the Human Torch now as I
mentioned the Human Torch is able to
assume a fiery form where he is
completely engulfed in flames and when
he's in this form he's able to fly in
addition to this his body isn't a heat
and fire which comes in handy when your
super power is bursting into flames it's
kind of necessary but furthermore the
Human Torch possesses power Kinesis
which allows him to create powerful
blasts of heat energy and capable of
causing incredible amounts of damage and
in Johnny's earliest appearances he did
not have much damage resistance as
practically any time he got hit he has
to power down into his human form
however over the years Human Torch has
been depicted as increasingly powerful
especially in terms of durability in his
flame form
now while Human Torch is not typically a
character that we think of when
discussing the most powerful Marvel
characters he's actually a pretty
under-the-radar powerhouse that's too
often overlooked
now as we'll see when we take a look at
some of the things of the humans
it's done it'll become clear that he's
definitely a planetary level threat
placing him well in the Omega level or
beyond range now starting with his
durability we've seen some incredible
feats of resistance e2 damage for
example the human torch has absorbed
blows from characters such as a nihilist
dragon man named with a submariner
and gladiator with the greatest of ease
and was relatively unharmed by Terrax a
Herald of Galactus in possession of the
power cosmic he also has sustained
energy blast from several high-ranking
characters without any ill effects
including Nova
serving as a Herald of Galactus and
oculus whose blasts were potent enough
to reduce mountains to rubble now the
Human Torch himself has said that the
heat shield he's able to generate is
strong enough to withstand anything
short of an atomic blast however on a
separate occasion he was actually shown
to absorb the energy of an atomic blast
so I think it's safe to say he could
survive a nuclear bomb however what
Johnny Storm seems to have in terms of
his being met with regards to his
offensive abilities his office of
abilities aren't nuts human torch's
primary power is as pyrokinesis which
can reach insanely high temperatures in
fact the fire the torch produces can
reach Nova like temperatures which has
allowed him to do things like destroy a
city sized Android his Nova flame is
also said to be equal in energy to a
nuclear blast so we know that he's able
to eliminate all life in a pretty wide
radius if he decided to now at one point
the torch goes Nova and wipes out a good
chunk of the annihilation wave which is
a threat that was sufficient enough to
call together most of Marvel's cosmic
based superheroes to take out so the
fact that Johnny is able to take out
several of them in one attack is pretty
impressive in another instance Johnny is
able to engulf a planet sized celestial
object in flame which makes him a
definite planetary threat since having
an entire planet be like you know
completely on fire would likely destroy
all life on that planet
however the torch's Nova blasts aren't
the only way that he can pose a
planetary threat one of his abilities is
the ability to draw moisture out of
others which is used in his fight with
the she-hulk now we don't know how large
of a scale he can perform this ability
on right we don't really know if it's
like planetary level or like a city size
level or something like that but if he
is able to do it with any real measure
of range he could either use it to draw
the moisture out of everyone within
range or perhaps absorb large quantities
of the water in the world's oceans which
could do such damage to the Earth's
climate that life is no
longer sustainable similarly the Human
Torch is able to absorb heat and
theoretically could absorb enough heat
to significantly lower the temperature
of the planet to the point that nothing
could survive similarly we've seen the
torch burn all the oxygen atoms from an
entire city created by the High
Evolutionary now this could be
problematic as people of course need
oxygen to live so if you can do this on
a planetary scale everybody on earth
would essentially suffocate and so there
are a few different ways the human torch
could probably destroy all life on the
planet itself now I say probably because
we haven't actually seen him do these
things on a large enough of a scale to
really say for sure but part of the fun
of these videos is kind of playing
around with different ideas and
extrapolating and extrapolating things
that could basically never happen but
will be kind of cool to see but anyway
we have seen him set an entire planet
size object on fire so even just going
by that on what we saw with the panels
of various other feeds the human torch
represents a planetary threat so he is
definitely app or a beyond omega-level
threat but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here - comments explained
admission you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
Bruce